China's foreign ministry said this
morning that President Trump's message
to the w-h-o threatening the cut off
funding for good is an effort to shift
the blame for his administration's
failures in responding to the
coronavirus rainy Inocencio reports now
on the letter sent in the middle of a
worldwide conference on the pandemic in
his scathing four-page letter president
Trump slammed the World Health
Organization for what he called a failed
response to Coba 19 an alarming lack of
independence from China and for ignoring
credible reports from Wuhan the
president's health and human services
secretary addressed the w-h-o directly
as it convened its annual assembly
virtually for the first time there was a
failure by this organization to obtain
the information that the world needed
and that failure cost many lives
the president's missive came after
China's President Xi Jinping made a
u-turn pledging to support an
independent probe into the origins of
the corona virus and with a pledge of
two billion dollars in aid but
Washington called Xi's statements a
distraction from what the White House
claims to be China's failure to alert
the world and said Beijing should pay
more that payment might come in the form
of a vaccine China says it now has five
candidates in clinical trial with
Cansino biologics the medical arm of the
People's Liberation Army the first in
the world to enter the second phase of
clinical trials typically from phase 1
to phase 3 studies can take five to
seven years given the urgency of the
pandemic those steps of being compressed
somewhat and the last paragraph of
president Trump's letter he threatened
to withdraw all US funding to the World
Health Organization for good that was
400 million dollars in 2019 unless major
changes are made in the next 30 days for
CBS this morning
ramie innocencio Tokyo